so here we are we have come to my 666
video and it happens to be a review for
the movie that conjuring just worked out
that way the conjuring - the conjuring
is the new haunting horror movie
directed by James Wan the director of
saw death sentence insidious and after
insidious almost like he was like you
know what I'm gonna make a horror movie
that people are gonna remember the
conjuring does do his job well you know
the formula by now family moves into a
new house through trinkets and things in
this new house and now a demon and
probably a couple of ghosts are going to
be haunting this house and terrorizing
this family then they come across the
Warrens niteowl from Watchmen and Vera
the hot chick it's their official name I
think they play a couple of paranormal
investigators they're ghost hunters
they're pretty much like taps but more
real and she's got that sixth sense
thing going on you know so she can see
some paranormal things that other people
can't see and what I liked about these
paranormal investigators in this movie
is that they debunk things they
ultimately go into these scenarios as
skeptics they're like not sorry it's the
crickety pipes utter that's the reason
you're hearing creaks in your house hey
not a ghost which makes you trust them
you're like okay if something actually
freaks these people out it's because
they genuinely believe it's an actual
poltergeist or a demon or a ghost or
something real yeah I listed off the
paranormal things as real not that not
the real crickety pipes now all these
elements come together in a movie that's
made to scare the living [ __ ] out of you
and this movie has some really effective
elements going on first of all the
acting was really good in the movie good
kid actors doesn't always happen but the
kids in this movie they were good when
they were scared shitless you could tell
you're like those kids are frightened
when people were supposed to be
frightened I believe they were
frightened if they're all stoic you can
tell they're like I'm just trying not to
show him scared but I'm actually scared
I was interested in this movie the
moment I found out the conjuring is
rated R because it's just scary that's
right no nudity no rated-r language no
sex no graphic blood scary that's why
it's rated R there's a part of me that
thinks that might be a bit gimmicky due
to the fact that I have seen rated pg-13
movies that have made my hair stand up
and the conjuring is rated R because
it's scary you know it's a rating to
illustrate a point so it's subjective
this movie
sells on the tension aspect you know the
camera will be panning into this really
dark corner and someone's scared to
death like they're seeing something and
just goose bumps are going up your head
and up your neck and you're just like
what's gonna happen the bummer is I feel
the trailer did show too much of this
movie in a movie that excels in tension
the audience is still human human beings
are pretty smart people we can piece
things together so in this tensions
building I start seeing the scenery in
the layout and who's in this room I'm
like wait a minute this person was in
this room in the trailer when this
happened okay so this is going to happen
when you piece that together before it
happens the tensions lost attention is
due to the fear of the unknown fear what
might happen and what might be there
without showing you or showing you just
enough to scare the [ __ ] out of you so
you can piece together the worst
scenario imaginable in your mind and you
can piece the end game together it takes
away from the movie and like any good
haunting movie the first half of this
movie is actually pretty slow but I like
slow buildup in movies like this usually
movies like this if it moves too fast in
the beginning there's not enough tension
I'm just not invested in it I don't have
that fear of the unknown just because
the movies going like a hundred miles an
hour generally speaking in movies like
this if a haunting movie's going to be
effective it will end up having a slow
build-up it's a give-and-take of
haunting movies the bummer is no matter
how much hype this movie has no matter
how much praise it has no matter how
many times people go do this movie
actually scared the living [ __ ] out of
me but they will not say is dude
everything in this movie is so new and
original the formula is very familiar
the build ups really good the execution
is really good it makes you have
goosebumps for a good 60 75 percent of
the movie that's awesome but it still is
familiar territory you're just not going
to get away from that the thing that did
bum me out about this movies everything
is just hitting the climax of the movie
no you're like alright this is it and
shits going down and it's getting all
real and then it just kind of end just
like alright and then the movie's over
and that's that you're like alright
abrupt but here we are that's fun I want
to get home anyway and re-watch season 5
of Breaking Bad before the new episodes
there so it all works out for it so as a
horror movie the conjuring is really
effective it's really creepy and has a
lot of good tension it's not going to be
original material but the execution is
actually really good it does this job
effectively in the sense that you get
home and every little creaky here in
your house you're like alright what was
that ambient noise you've heard a
hundred times over subconsciously but
pay no mind to it
cuz you didn't just watch a horror movie
and you watch one you're like oh these
are new sounds and they're not yeah
that's what's happening I will say the
conjuring is worth buying on blu-ray one
of those movies that you're like have
some friends over on Halloween watch it
in the dark and just freak each other
out or so here is the million dollar
question what movie do you find scarier
the conjuring or sinister that's the
scale right there man whichever one you
find scarier comment below let me know
or if it's neither list another one I
guess and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more